whether you're hunting for that thousand
g or that elusive platinum trophy
there's something endlessly satisfying
about a digital high five when you nail
a feat within a game and then there are
those achievements which can only be
described as masochistic you'd have to
be truly dedicated to a game to earn
kudos from it for accomplishing
something that very few players will
even try to attempt we've rounded up 20
of the toughest achievements you'll
probably never get
this one is an absolute doozy as you'll
need to not only complete the mile high
club mission in under a minute you'll
have to do so on veteran difficulty in a
level that's best described as a high
altitude meat grinder you'll need to
have incredible speed reflexes and
marksmanship just to survive the small
army of enemies with a lot of luck
memorization and an arsenal of
flashbangs it is possible to skydive to
safety at the end of this challenging
call of duty gauntlet
the original dead rising is a
masterclass in goofy b-movie horror and
racing against the clock and to claim
the seven-day survivor achievement
you'll need to survive in infinity mode
for 14 hours straight sounds easy right
the catch here is that your health is
constantly depleting health restoring
food doesn't respawn and no saving is
allowed thanks to strategies from the
dead rising community this achievement
is doable and you won't have to worry
about frank starving to death while
surrounded by hordes of flesh-eating
mole rats in dead space no one can hear
you scream about the devastatingly
difficult hardcore mode in this
follow-up to visceral game's iconic
cosmic adventure still as terrifying as
ever you'll need to guide isaac clarke
through a space station of horror with
only a handful of resources very little
ammo tougher enemies and only a trio of
save points horrifyingly simple and
brutal is the best way to describe this
achievement not only do you have to
survive the evil within on akumu mode
faster tougher and more numerous enemies
but you'll need to have the reflexes of
a cat because almost everything on this
setting can kill you in a single hit
it's like an inverse one punch man game
this seriously achievement has long been
a trademark challenge of the gears of
war series and gears 5 wasn't ready to
break that tradition to get this
achievement you'll need nerves and
trigger fingers of steel as you'll have
to complete the campaign on the hardest
difficulty mode of insane complete the
master hoard and escape launch maps on
master difficulty reach level 100 and
re-up back to level 1 a total of 20
times and reach the level of general in
a tour of duty seriously it's a
challenge of both difficulty and
endurance with gta 5 back in the
headlines as it hops on over to xbox
series xns and ps5 now is a great time
to experience the game's superb online
mode and attempt to become a legend in
the community skill planning and a crew
you can rely on will help you earn the
mastermind achievement as you'll need to
complete three criminal mastermind
scenarios in gta online with the same
team of players on hard difficulty and
without losing any lives on setups or
finales this achievement is a paradox
because while it might fit the bill of
being masochistic it's also strangely
fun in half-life 2 episode 2 you'll need
to find a secret hidden garden gnome and
carry it through the entire game
eventually placing it in a rocket and
launching it into space while you could
place a little ceramic fellow down so
that you could wield a gun in tough
situations this challenge also served as
a reminder of the fancy physics in
half-life 2 because you could easily
lose the gnome along the way drive too
fast while it's in your dune buggy for
example and it would go flying off the
back it's a silly and oftentimes painful
achievement to pursue but little
rocketman is a gloriously creative task
that shows off just how great valve
sequel was at the time skulls have been
a cherished part of each halo game
offering a wide variety of quirky and
downright punishing modifiers to each
game's campaign for the wonderful time
capsule that is the master chief
collection you can earn maximum kudos by
declaring yourself a lasso master with
this achievement be prepared for a
brutal ride though as each mainline
game's collection of skulls offers a
galaxy of hurt and hilarious deaths
along the way completing limbo a three
to four hour game in a single session
and only dying five times or less sounds
deceptively easy anyone who has played
the game is well aware of just how often
death creeps up on them in that iconic
platformer and even if you are prepared
for what lies ahead surviving those
lethal obstacles is easier said than
done earning this achievement requires a
virtually encyclopedic knowledge of the
game's world it's time to feel the pain
in this challenge as not only do you
have to play the game until the
difficulty mode of new york minute is
unlocked you'll need to once again
finish it on that mode that means no
saving or dying throughout the entire
campaign and if that's not hard enough
for you you'll need to do so with a
strict time limit pushing you to be more
reckless than ever before capcom's
iconic blue bomber is an enduring part
of the company's legacy but for this
achievement he also needs to evolve into
an untouched exterminator of rogue
robots mr perfect sounds simple on paper
as you'll need to complete the mega man
10 campaign without taking a single hit
it's easier said than done thanks to the
army of killer machines deadly level
design and brutal bots in each stage so
be prepared to die a lot if you attempt
to become an untouchable mega man master
hideo kojima has a cruel sense of humor
a solid snake's final chronological
outing in the metal gear solid series is
an exercise in sadism to earn the trophy
for legendary hero you'll need to first
get all of the other trophies in the
game and complete the campaign on its
hardest difficulty setting oh and you'll
have to avoid killing a single person
abstain entirely from health packs and
not get detected by any enemies in under
five hours good luck getting that
platinum trophy soldier you're going to
need to really really like mortal
kombat's 2011 edition to earn this
reward play as every character in the
game for 24 hours in total win 100
fights pull off 100 fatalities perform
150 x-ray hits spill 10 000 liters of
blood and you'll be recognized as the
undisputed master of mortal kombat no
checkpoints no saves the highest
difficulty in a brutal survival horror
game and the challenge of surviving on a
single flashlight battery while deadly
forces stalk you from the shadows is the
messiah achievement possible absolutely
although your heart might give in
halfway through thanks to the sheer
stress of the terror that you'll have to
endure complete the game without dying
that's it that's the challenge and if
you've played this superb metroidvania
platformer you know that the task is not
impossible to accomplish unless you
start cheesing the use of backup saves
on easy mode it's something that can be
accomplished in a single four hour run
if you know what you're doing but you'll
feel like you've aged a few decades
thanks to the stress of this sequel's
beautifully lethal level design
overwatch has an achievement that few
people have acquired due to the setup
that it requires the flaw is lava is
earned when you take down three enemies
in a single life while playing as lucio
and using a wall ride an objective that
needs cosmic levels of fate and skill to
be on your side in a game with tightly
contested kill death ratios and constant
rebalancing of its characters you'll
have to hope that you get matched up
against a team of confused possums who
just
love to hang out on the edge of maps
you'll need the endurance of a le mans
driver or a catheter to add rock band
2's toughest achievement to your list as
bladder of steel requires you to
complete all 84 songs in endless setlist
2 without failing a single one of them
or pausing
once
that should take you roughly over 6
hours to accomplish but at least you'll
be doing the pp dance to some good music
sniper elite games have always been
strangely cathartic exercises in messily
rearranging the faces of nazi soldiers
but the game's highest honor requires
unairing aim and precision it's a
straightforward task that requires you
to beat the game on authentic plus
difficulty and without manually saving
as a reminder of how difficult that mode
is authentic plus features reduced
supplies and enemies who are relentless
in their pursuit of you if they hear so
much as a grenade pin drop i hope you're
patient because the stanley parable's
cheekiest achievement requires turning
the game on and then turning it off for
the next five years after half a decade
has passed come back inside to start the
game all over again and you'll be
greeted with a fresh trophy for this
zero effort challenge wolfenstein 2's
most colossal achievement requires you
to make it through the entire campaign
unscathed which is quite the feat
considering how relentless the ai
soldiers are with the difficulty cranked
to the max with a single life to use as
you tear through ubersoldatin and no
save points around earning this
accomplishment will make you feel like
the real terrorbilly that nazis have
learned to fear over the years
do you have any of the achievements or
trophies on this list and if so which
ones brag about them in the comments
below for more videos just like this one
make sure to subscribe to gamespot and
we'll catch you next time